it's not rocket science in terms of what
we need to do I'm in favor of the Second
Amendment but we need an assault weapons
ban no we don't and if you've watched
the news the last two weeks it's not
rocket science between hamas's recent
attack on Israel and Russia's invasion
of Ukraine the reason to own an assault
weapon or a few is pretty clear the
Second Amendment isn't about hunting
self-defense or sport shooting it's
about protecting yourself against
tyranny and speaking of threats FBI
director Christopher Ray just warned of
growing Terror threats on us soil but
sure Kamal keep pushing gun control
during the same speech the vice
president talked about a bunch of
feckless people in Congress but what's
actually careless is calling for more
gun control after a time when people
needed weapons the most